en tunisie le président kaïs sayyed a
décidé de prolonger les mesures
exceptionnelles prises le 25 juillet
dernier avec le gel des activités du
parlement et la levée de l'immunité des
députés depuis un mois il s'est lancé
dans une véritable opération de
nettoyage en s'attaquant à la corruption
elle est désormais seul à la tête du
pays et bien que certains opposants y
voient un danger pour la démocratie
le chef d'état tunisien jouit du soutien
d'une large partie de la population est
les précisions de bassam chez lise à
tunis
une annonce loin d'être une surprise en
tunisie celle de la prolongation du gel
des activités parlementaires et de la
levée de l'immunité des députés le
président de la république ait sayyed a
émis un décret dans la nuit du lundi à
mardi qui prolonge les mesures
exceptionnelles mises en oeuvre en vertu
de l'article 82 la constitution et ce
jusqu'à nouvel ordre depuis sa prise de
contrôle de l'état le président ça aide
n'a toujours pas nommé de nouveau au
gouvernement ni dévoiler de feuille de
route réclamée par de nombreux partis
politiques
associations et citoyens déterminés à
combattre la corruption et à opérer des
changements significatifs dans le pays
le chef de l'état peut compter sur le
soutien d'une large partie de la
population
ces tunisiens qui semble avoir mis tous
leurs espoirs dans le coup d'éclat du 25
juillet depuis qu'il a pris ses
premières décisions le président kaïs
temps n'a pas pris une seule qui soit
mauvaises elles sont toutes bonnes et
elles sont toutes dans l'intérêt du
peuple si ça ne tenait qu'à moi ce
parlement je le laisserai fermer afin
qu'on puisse être tranquille moi je n'ai
pas peur de sa nouvelle décision car à
l'heure actuelle il est le seul en qui
nous avons confiance il n'y a plus
aucune confiance dans tous les autres à
mon sens la meilleure décision c'est
celle qu'il a prise je ne suis pas le
seul à avoir attendu une telle décision
tout le peuple attendait cela je n'ai
pas du tout peur au contraire je suis
très content le président doit
s'accorder un autre délai pour
travailler correctement réfléchir et ne
pas se précipiter pendant dix ans nous a
affamé nous on blâmait ben ali et voilà
qu'on se retrouve maintenant avec une
dizaine de ben ali
exaspérés par leur classe politique ceux
qui attendaient de la révolution de 2011
un renouveau politique et économique ont
fait qu'encaisser désillusion sur des
illusions ces dix dernières années
aujourd'hui nombre d'entre eux attendent
des actes forts de la part du président
sayyed notamment en matière de lutte
contre la corruption le chômage et
l'impunité dans un pays où la situation
sociale économique et sanitaire n'a
cessé de se dégrader du côté du palais
de carthage on annonce que le chef de
l'état devrait s'adresser très
prochainement à la nation sans préciser
de date